[Música]
vamos ya con la economía aquí en directo
América edición nocturna Para ello ya
Contamos con nuestro compañero Juan
Pablo lucumic qué tal estás Todo está
muy bien Buenas noches muy buenas noches
vamos a empezar con el anuncio de
renuncia en uno de los principales
bancos del mundo Rodrigo hablamos nada
más y nada menos que el Banco Mundial
David malpaz a un año de terminar su
periodo de 5 años escribió en su cuenta
de Twitter aurocomillas esta tarde me
reuní con el directorio ejecutivo del
grupo del Banco Mundial y les informé de
mi intención de marcharme hacia el 30 de
junio de este año fiscal ha sido un
honor y privilegio servir como
presidente del Banco Mundial Aunque dijo
que los últimos años han sido muy
significativos para su carrera y que ha
progresado mucho malpaz propuesto por
Donald Trump ocupaba el cargo desde
abril de 2019 y dijo que ahora planea
perseguir nuevos desafíos el economista
había generado polémica cuando llegó al
puesto por sus constantes críticas a la
institución por ejemplo Rodrigo una vez
dijo que los únicos que se beneficiaban
los créditos del Banco Mundial son
quienes vuelan en primera clase Bueno
desde luego muy polémicas esas
declaraciones vamos ahora con noticias
de América Latina y arrancamos en Perú
Así es la economía de Perú creció un
2,68% en 2022 lo que supone una fuerte
desaceleración si se compara con el
13,61% que registró en 2021 bastante
amplia la economía peruana se desaceleró
por segundo mes consecutivo incumpliendo
los pronósticos para el último mes de
2022 mientras el país se enfrenta a una
ola de malestar social que comenzó a
principios de diciembre Pues seguimos
ahora con Colombia porque hay datos de
la economía Cómo le fue así es también
de Colombia porque creció un 7,5% en
2022 lo que significa 3,1 puntos menos
que el 10,6% de 2021 estuvo por debajo
de las proyecciones de entidades locales
pero también decepcionó al fondo
monetario internacional qué pronosticó
un porcentaje mayor el FM y recomendó el
martes a Colombia que mantenga las
políticas restrictivas que buscan
reducir la inflación y los
desequilibrios en las cuentas externas
ya veremos que haga el gobierno pues del
gobierno de Colombia pasamos al de
Brasil porque hoy el presidente Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva hizo una
Monumental promesa a los ciudadanos Así
es Rodrigo se comprometió a retomar
14.000 obras de infraestructura que
están paralizadas en todo el país esas
obras han generado un millar de empleos
en la que es una de las regiones más
pobres de Brasil que según dijo Lula
será central en la retoma del trabajo de
la infraestructura y nos vamos ahora a
Estados Unidos con Los indicadores Bueno
vamos a los indicadores de las bolsas de
manera general Y empezamos con Estados
Unidos porque hoy airbnb se disparó un
13,3% en la bolsa tras los primeros
beneficios anuales de su historia la
plataforma ganó
1773 millones de euros el año pasado
esto hizo que cerrara pues de nasdaq con
una ganancia acercándose al 1% con la
esperanza de una economía resiliente
luego el dato de inflación del martes
las bolsas europeas siguieron la senda
de Estados Unidos con indicador de París
reportando ganancias de 1,21 por ciento
el de Londres con un 0,55 y el de
Frankfurt de Alemania con un 0,82 en
nuestra región también hubo ganancia los
principales indicadores de Brasil México
y Argentina reportaron ganancias por
encima del 1,3%, lo que supone de manera
general un día positivo para los
indicadores pues las cifras de las
bolsas vamos a la cifra del día que no
estáis ahí así es el 10,3% interanual
eso fue lo que cayeron las ventas de
videojuegos en China en 2022 según la
conferencia anual de industrias del
juego en China la pandemia impidió el
desarrollo de nuevos productos y esto se
tradujo en una ralentización de la
economía que afectó a la financiación de
las compañías a los consumos de los
usuarios usted también juega bastante No
yo juego poquito pero a veces sí por ahí
estuvimos bueno Muchas gracias por este
repaso económico te invito a que sigas
con nosotros en directo a que vamos
hasta Colombia